Hi I'm Shanea,
a program manager at Google.
Prior to Google,
I started a digital marketing agency to
help women entrepreneurs, authors, and
experts develop and
launch their businesses online.
Welcome to the Tech Entrepreneur
nanodegree program.
I am really excited to join you on your
journey to becoming an entrepreneur.
A few things that you can expect are,
interviews with authors, investors, and
industry experts to give you deep
insights on your new role as a founder.
Project submissions and one on one
coaching to get feedback on your
business ideas and course material
meds help support you along the way.
Coming up, we'll look further into what
you'll be doing throughout the program.
So let's get started.